los líderes de la junta militar dicen
que han perdonado y liberado a más de
23.000 encarcelados sin embargo se cree
que muy pocos de los que han sido
arrestados desde el golpe militar se
encuentran entre los liberados y nos
acaban de liberar después de
aproximadamente dos meses y medio dentro
todavía no sabemos ni entendemos mucho
de lo que está sucediendo afuera grupos
defensores de derechos humanos dicen que
alrededor de 3000 manifestantes han sido
detenidos desde que los militares
tomaron el poder el 1 de febrero los
manifestantes salieron nuevamente el
sábado para dar la bienvenida a los
movimientos que buscan establecer un
gobierno de unidad nacional compuesto
por miembros del gabinete derrocado de
la unsam sus líderes del movimiento de
protesta y representantes de los
principales grupos étnicos minoritarios
del país tenemos grandes esperanzas de
un gobierno que pueda competir con el
régimen militar a partir de aquí
esperamos que nuestro país pueda
convertirse en una democracia federal
quiero que la constitución se establezca
y tenga éxito no quiero que se pierdan
más jóvenes
las últimas protestas se producen cuando
el jefe militar de mianmar confirma que
tendrá su primera reunión con líderes
extranjeros desde el golpe viajará a
indonesia para una reunión de la
asociación de naciones del sudeste
asiático el viernes